thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and I am incredibly excited to
have the famous H bomber guy with us
today why don't we talk a little bit
about your channel itself you have just
exploded in popularity as being some of
the best social commentary on YouTube
and one of the best Donkey Kong players
I suppose is out there technically I'm
one of the worst like this eventually
well you know what depends on what the
ultimate goal is is it beat the game or
is it to do it in a very very difficult
way in the most amusing way possible I
guess is that yeah and well one thing
that I think was amazing as I guess AOC
commented on your live stream right yeah
yeah people were joking about getting
her on and I thought that's quite fun
but then an account that was AOC joined
the call and it was actually her voice
and I lost my mind hello hi it's
fantastic to meet you would you like to
introduce yourself in case some people
don't know who you are
my name is Alexandria Ocasio Cortese I
am the congresswoman for New York's 14th
congressional district and now like
Bernie Sanders is doing streaming so
Hillary people that people following
suit I started a trend in left-wing
American politics by accident while
trying to make fun of a former comedian
in Britain but these things happen and
how much did you raise for charity about
330,000 oh that's incredible so what
kind of legal questions can I help
answer for you well I was wondering on
behalf of semi political youtubers how
can one broach important and contentious
topics with people who might sometimes
be litigious without putting themselves
at legal risk I I can't imagine that you
ever run into these kind of issues on on
YouTube this is purely - solutely
understandable I mean none of us have
ever run into these kinds of issues
well it's interesting from my
perspective is that the US and the UK
have very different definition laws when
it comes to talking about individuals
and corporations and
where the line is in terms of what is
commentary and what crosses the line
into a defamatory statement hmm and
traditionally there's been a difference
between libel which is written and
slander which is spoken and these days
that distinction doesn't really matter
anymore as an American lawyer I'm not an
expert in the UK but what I can tell you
is that in the u.s. at least when you
are talking about these kinds of
commentary issues where you run into
defamation the key is that defamation
only applies to a provable statement of
fact and that is false so you know it's
most people know that the at least in
the US and this is not true in all
countries that truth is a defense to
defamation but the underlying statement
itself has to be a provable statement of
fact so it can't be an opinion
it can't be hyperbole it can't be
ridiculousness and and parody there's a
famous case in the US where the
pornographic magazine penthouse owned by
Larry Flynt did a spread about Jerry
Falwell losing his virginity and all the
ridiculous hijinks that ensued and he
sued for defamatory purposes and the
court held basically as a matter of law
that it was so ridiculous that no one
would have believed that a Jerry Falwell
gave this interviewed a penthouse and B
that he actually did these things in the
course of losing his virginity
so really the more ridiculous something
is that almost becomes more of a defense
even when you start edging into the
realm of things that are factual in
nature at least on YouTube the kind of
commentary that you see most often is
things that are people's opinion you
might call someone a jerk or you know
much worse but it's really when you get
into these discrete pieces of factual
information that are factually wrong
that you have an issue and I don't know
if you're familiar with the extra
standard of a celebrity but in the in
the US if you are someone of notoriety
and a certain amount of celebrity you
actually have to show that the person
when they made the false statement of
fact
that they knew it was false and
false and they said it with what's
called malicious intent
so that becomes even more difficult when
you're talking about say politicians or
famous billionaires I can see now why
certain politicians will cover
themselves by saying well to the best of
my knowledge so they're not obviously
lying or they'll only provide facts that
support their beliefs and just those
facts and they're not lying they're just
only showing a very careful vote as a
truth right exactly and you know even in
the context of politicians we've seen
several defamation lawsuits against
President Trump at the moment he is
currently in a lawsuit with a woman
named summer servos who has said that
the president defamed her by saying that
he did not engage in certain sexual
activities with her and called her a
liar and that's going to be somewhat of
a groundbreaking lawsuit because it's
going to be a question of whether she's
a private person or someone of note
whether the president is a private
person or not I mean usually they are
not considered private they have that
amount of celebrity and whether his
statement of saying that she was a liar
is something that it's a provable
statement and the factor whether that's
hyperbole and an opinion I remember a
suit well you know Jim sterling I do yes
it was sued for fifteen million dollars
or something by someone on account of of
libel slander very stuff like that it
was an equivalent sort of suit and one
of the things they listed as one of the
grievances was at some point he said
there's not enough popcorn in the world
to sort of laugh at this person for how
how dumb they're being and this was put
in the suit as like a quote as one of
the grievances yeah so and one of the
things they were considering doing was
challenging them to prove that there
wasn't in a corner in the world
I'm guessing Jim sterling probably won
that lawsuit he got dropped with
prejudice I believe in the end okay yeah
if it was dismissed by the court on the
substance of the issue then likely they
they can't bring it up again
okay it's good sometimes I make factual
statements and then because we're not
perfect you discover later that some of
the facts you've mentioned are
themselves selective or or mistakes or
wrong in which case I have in a sense
told a lie
like is there is there a legal precedent
for someone saying a falsehood and
getting in trouble for saying it even if
they believed it at
well that that's a great question and I
but partially hinges on the nature of
the person that is spoken about there's
no cause of action for just saying a
falsehood in public defamation applies
to when you are directing a false
statement of fact towards an individual
person that harms their reputation so an
innocent mistake of merely saying
something that was incorrect but you've
thought it to be true if you're talking
about someone that is a celebrity or of
note likely the that is not grounds for
defamation because you have to meet that
extra hurdle to get into the actual
malice standard when you're talking
about the celebrity I see that's great
one one more question please I have a
question about the definition if there's
a proper legal definition of the concept
of being libel proof in the sort of
anime voice acting scene that's
currently a spurious lawsuit by a
certain voice actor against a company
for supposedly ball and the
counter-argument the company is making
is that this this person is effectively
impossible to do libel towards because
they have done so many other things that
at this point it's barely making
anything up to assert certain things yes
so that is a potential defense that
simple and the court can find that what
would normally be a defamatory statement
is not defamatory in this context
because the reputation is so bad it
can't get any worse Harry thank you so
much for joining this episode of the
yet-to-be-named legal legal interview
show thank you and if you could you know
pass the information along to AOC and
we'll get her on the hot seat for the
next one don't be really great to hear
but I think the owners at this house
they're coming back so we could probably
get out of it all right let's get out of
here Harry thanks for doing the
interview and thanks for dressing up for
the occasion no no look I love the robe
over the pajamas look but you know maybe
for next time you'd like something a
little bit nicer like a I don't know
custom-made suit no Gina you know if
you're looking for an awesome slim cut
suit I can't recommend endo Chino highly
enough and as you know all of my suits
are now made by endo Tino including this
jacket that I'm wearing right now
which was custom made just for me see
the secret to
great suit is all about the fit and as
you can tell since we're actually in
person physically talking to each other
I'm a reasonably athletic guy and the
problem is I can never buy suits off the
rack because they simply just never fit
right both Indo Chino you can send in
your measurements online or you can go
to one of their stores and have a
stylist take your measurements I made an
appointment went to a store in person
and had a stylist work with me for over
ninety minutes when I went in for the
first time my personal stylist took my
measurements and a couple of weeks later
I got the best fitting suit of my entire
life it was perfect right out of the box
you could even get measured in the
pajamas that you're wearing right now as
you're listening to what I am telling
you in person
endo Chino will make you a fully custom
tailored suit specifically for you for
less than four hundred dollars and the
best part is they still use the best
materials like super 130 wool and
cashmere in fact I asked Indo Chino to
give legal eagles specifically the best
deal possible and they're giving you
guys meaning Harry the exclusive ability
to buy any premium suit for just 359
that is the best deal you can find
anywhere I will never buy an
off-the-rack suit again once you try it
neither will you legal eagles can get
any premium Indo Chino suit for just
three hundred fifty nine dollars when
you enter the code legal eagle at
checkout or use the link in the
description
clicking on the link really helps out
this channel Sno Chino calm promo code
legal eagle for the best custom suit of
your entire life